i'm hoping that you can set the record
straight on this
social media war that some fans seem to
think you've started
against your ex travis barker's new
girlfriend
kourtney kardashian is that true i
honestly had no
bad intentions whatsoever um you know
travis and i haven't been together for
almost a decade
and um you know we co-parent together
we're friends
however um you know i don't know
anything about his personal life like
that we're not um
as close like that anymore you know i
mean it's been 10 years he has his own
world going on i kind of have my own
world
um do i want him to be happy absolutely
i want him to
um i want him to be happy and you know
she makes him happy i think that's
awesome
you know sadly i guess that i liked a
comment
on social media i honestly didn't i
don't remember
liking that comment uh sometimes when
i'm on my social media i'll like all the
fans comments i just kind of go down
and like everything i try to interact
with my my social media
my fans my friends my family and i guess
i liked a comment that was disparaging
um and you know when i saw the headlines
i was like what is this
what did i like i had to kind of go back
and look at it i didn't even realize
people were looking at the things that i
hearted
you know i just was trying to be
supportive of my fan base
and uh didn't didn't even realize it
okay i will from now on
there were a couple things that people
interpreted as you posting that could be
throwing
shade i mean how do you explain that you
know i
i just have fun on my social media and
not you know i post silly quotes i post
um quotes that i think women will relate
to
um and it's all in good fun for me i
don't take social media
as serious as i think a lot of other
people do
if i wanted to say something i think the
world knows
me as being um outgoing enough if i
wanted to really make a comment i would
just make a comment i wouldn't be doing
these
um i guess cryptic messages to the world
i even saw like one one thing where i
believe
um i think my ex gave um courtney
flowers
and she posted that which i think is
beautiful and then the next night
i was out with my guy and we just
happened i
we happened to see this woman who sells
roses that i've known since i was 19
years old
she was so excited to see me she gave me
all these roses and you know i posted it
because i was so happy to see her and
then people thought
that oh because he gave her flowers i
was posting flowers
and you know it's just all kind of it
was just
silly to me you know and that's the kind
of thing where people are putting things
together that really had absolutely no
you know correlation together at all so
okay well i thank you for sharing that
backstory hopefully that
and a little more context as to what's
going on
um i i do want to ask do you know
courtney
i don't no i do not know her at all um
i have no ill will towards her um you
know as long as she's good to my
children this is the biggest point that
i keep saying
and my kids like her my kids do like her
that's all i care about you know my kids
are happy they're happy
i have my my own things going on and
um and and i think that's great you know
i wish them all the best
so you just said your kids like her um
what have they told you what have you
heard um they just said that she's
really sweet
and she's she's really nice to them um i
i know she's given them a lot of gifts
as well um that i i know that they love
and appreciate
as much as travis and i may have not
agreed in the past on a lot of things
and we've had our own public
um you know ups and downs um you know
uh we've always shared the fact that our
children
are first priority of of course courtney
is now ending
her run on keeping up with the
kardashians and they're going to be
doing a new
um docu-series where we're going to be
seeing their lives you know again on
television
have you spoken with your kids about
whether or not they have permission to
be on the show are they gonna be on the
show
i haven't heard anything about it you
know i've never even seen one episode of
keeping up with the kardashians
if my kids wanted to participate um i'm
all for it you know that's something
that travis and i
as legal guardians would have to come
together and talk about
um but if they would want to be on it
i'm absolutely okay with that
have you and courtney spoken or has she
reached out have you reached out
no we haven't spoke or reached out to
each other and i don't really think it's
my
um my place or um nor should she have to
you know i mean like i said i haven't
been with my ex-husband for over a
decade
we're friendly and we co-parent but i
don't think it's really any of my
business what's going on in his personal
life i don't want him in my personal
life
so is there any message that you want to
put into the universe
surrounding all these headlines that
have been out there i'm going to let you
kind of speak your truth and clear the
air
i'm i'm happy for the both of them um i
hope they have a long lasting and
fulfilling relationship um
you know i want to see the father of my
children happy
it's only going to make him a better dad
and i'm in a good place and i hope they
would like to see me happy so
that i can be the best mother that i can
possibly be as well
um and you know like i said my kids are
are my priority and i want them i want
them to be happy and as long as they are
then
i'm happy i love it don't read so much
into social media people it's not that
deep and it's supposed to be fun
social media is supposed to be fun you
know i've you know i got
kind of attacked pretty brutal on social
media it's just kind of trolling and
just people saying horrible things
you look horrible you're ugly you're
this you're that
yeah you know it's my page and i clean
it up and i keep it positive
because i want people to come to my page
and have a positive experience
i don't want people fighting one another
or bashing or
her fans and my fans attacking one
another it's not what i'm about
so um you know i just delete i you know
i now pronounce you blocked and deleted
how much of the smile that i'm seeing
the
the light in your eyes how much of that
is a result of this new relationship
that you're in
i'm super happy we've been you know kind
of together for about a year now
and um i'm just in a really good place
okay tell us a little bit about your man
what's his name
how'd you guys meet i want the whole
backstory um his name is matthew rondeau
um he's an up-and-coming actor and model
we met on
instagram and it's been really awesome
ever since so who slid into whose dms
so i went to his instagram i followed
him but then he wrote me and was like
hey what's up and i was like hey
how are you and it kind of went from
there
and the rest is history and the rest is
history yeah yeah
super happy so you said you've been
together a year
um how serious are things we definitely
use the l word and we we're quarantined
buddies it started off as just
quarantined buddies and then it kind of
um spiraled into uh more of a
relationship
so yeah um it's interesting dating in
quarantine
because you know you're kind of thrusted
into living like
a married couple almost you know i mean
you're kind of
you're together 24 7 and you can't go
out to dinners and stuff but
um we had an awesome summer and an
awesome quarantine together
so it sounds like things are going great
yes
you've been married in the past is that
something that you see in your future
again
i think it's really important to not
ever let one of your past relationships
make you afraid to fall in love again
i would walk down that aisle again for
sure i think it would be beautiful but
i'm in no rush you know if it happens it
happens if it doesn't it's okay
you know um i'm just trying to through
this pandemic just live my best life and
you know spend time with my kids and
focus on my work
and just enjoy kind of where i'm at in
this place in my life
i have my pageants coming up in june and
august uh for
um miss nevada usa and utah usa so i'm
planning those productions
i'm creating a bikini line that's going
to be coming out in the next six months
and i've been working
with david allen nutrition and we're
creating a
wellness line had a pretty incredible
weight loss journey
and i'm really proud of my results and
where i'm
at and i would love to kind of share
with other women how i did it and how
they can do it because it's completely
[Music]
possible